each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
Alice was a grad student at Berkeley UC
Berkeley under michael jordan and she
graduated in 2005 she was also an intern
in the old signal processing group twice
in 2000-2001 where we worked on auto DJ
stuff but lately you've been at CMU and
as a postdoc and she's going to talk
about well I let her give her the title
of her slide but please welcome Alice
thanks ok so I want to talk about
statistical failure debugging today in
software and systems so why why are we
interested in failure diagnosis well
because failures are very common for
instance how many times have you seen
this message in the past week when
you're trying to access a website or if
you're like me then you have painful
memories of the gray screen of death of
Mac OS 10 and there some of you might
also remember the Mars rover spirit
which failed due to a software bug 17 17
days after landing on Mars so the
problem with failures is that they can
be very costly and not just in terms of
negative negative publicity generated by
by by the bugs themselves and lots of
customers lots of revenue for the
software company involved it could also
lead to performance degradation and even
system compromises in the worst cases
and dealing with failures take a lot of
time and energy so for instance it took
a whole team of NASA scientists working
around the clock two and a half weeks to
find and fix that bug on the Mars rover
and the question that I want to ask they
today is whether we can do better so our
goals for debugging is first of all we
have to admit the defeat in that there
will always be bugs so a study done by
computer world
claims that on average there is about 10
bugs at least per thousand lines of code
that that an average programmer writes
so we can't possibly catch all of them
before deployment yeah then here but
that's the that's the stat they they
cited I don't know how they aggregated
the istick but they probably just you
know counted a number of bugs and then
just averaged over a number of a number
of lines in the code I'm not saying that
if you write just one line there's ten
bugs and if you write two there's
there's 20 anyway so there's a lot of
bugs in the code and you can't catch
them is the point before deployment so
our goal is to get rid of the bugs as
soon as we can and to get rid of the
bugs affecting the most number of users
so how do we do this right now largely
manually so if i have a small program
then thought I want to debug and the
first thing that I'm on that I might do
to try to debug that program is simply
insert a whole bunch of princess
statement so everywhere where I think
the everywhere where I think the value
of that variables is that variable is
important I will add some printf
statement print out the current value at
that point run the program look at what
what it does and things like that the
problem with this approach is that it
it's not very scalable so the stats that
I can find as I windows XP has 14 over
40 million lines of code I don't know if
that's really true but we can't do
printf statements for everywhere for 40
million lines of code other debugging
approaches things like gb or visual c++
run into the problem that what if your
program crashes only after 20 hours of
runtime or what if your program only
crashes when you're also running an mp3
player in the background or something
like that so in short manual diagnosis
difficult because of the thousands of
software and hardware components at
stake
that are typically involved in the large
system and it's difficult because you
have to deal with all kinds of different
bugs so you have to kind of worried
about you know catching all different
kinds of failure errors when you're when
you're debugging a program so some
companies have started collecting crash
feedback reports for instance every time
the Mac Mac browser Safari quits I can
send in this report that contains a
simple stack maybe some other tiny bits
of information like the path of the
program the other libraries that are
loaded at the time etc and what the
company might do on the back end is
bucket the report these reports by saks
signature and prioritize the debugging
efforts based on the size of the bucket
so what the tool that I'm going to talk
about which I call statistical software
debugging gives you something like this
instead it has basically it's rank list
of predicate each predicate is basically
a specific condition associated with a
specific line and in the file and
insights and function so this list says
it seems that the conditions der kampf
not equal to 0 is associated with 1528
number of failed ones and these things
are listed in order of the number of
failed ones that are associated with and
if you click on each predicate you can
bring up a list of related predicate so
these are all the predicates all the
other predicates that seem to affect the
same set of failed runs so this
automatic debugger tries to
simultaneously isolate multiple bugs and
I'm going to show you how this the
system enabled an outside programmer
someone who's never seen the source code
before to find and fix bugs three
long-standing bugs in some real-world
program in less than 20 minutes each
so a quick overview of the system we
start with a program we instrument the
program I'll tell you more about how we
put what i mean by instrumenting and
what do we do there we disseminate the
instrumental version of the program out
into the field where users run this
instrumental version as opposed to the
normal version and we collect runtime
reports from all of these program runs
and analyze the successes and failures
to try to locate the suspicious-looking
predicates there are bug predictors so
I'm I'm going to focus mostly on well
sorry I'm first going to go over the
instrumentation and data collection
process to give you an idea of what kind
of data we collect and most of the top
will be focused on the algorithmic
challenges and what do we do to analyze
this data now this is joint work with
been LED lit my advisor mike jordan Alex
Aiken and Meyer naik Ben and Alex and
Maya are software engineering folks and
they focus mostly on the software the
the instrumentation and collection part
of the system yes seems like this
approach actually probably isn't very
appropriate for the Mars rover they you
mentioned the beginning yes yeah that
was just a motivating example of why we
care about failures in general we can't
decide what we can't have a thousand
Mars rovers all hunting on larson and
running amok and collecting data from
them right ok so the instrumentation
framework has this goal of collecting
detailed instrument useful information
for debugging so we want to do this on
each rung of the program and we want to
do this on a lot of internal variables
inside the program the what the report
that we get out might look something
like this we have a bunch of program
predicates specific conditions return
values of function calls and the data is
how many times that predicate was found
to be true during the
run of the program so a small example we
might suppose this as the code that we
start out with if X is equal to 0 then
we go into some loop we execute this
function y times after instrumentation
all of these all of these predicates get
automatically inserted into the program
so for instance we check every branch
statement and count the number of times
at that branch statement is true or
false and that every integer scalar
assignments like we compare that integer
scalar to all the other variables and
constants that are in scope at that
point and for function calls we with an
integer return value we again compare
the return value against zero because
oftentimes in C programs at least
programmers use the return value of a
function to indicate the exit status of
that function whether it succeeded or
failed so given so there so what ends up
happening during instrumentation is that
hundreds of thousands of predicates get
automatically inserted into the program
and we can't possibly execute every
single one of them at runtime so they're
sampled which creates problems later on
that I'll talk about but in the meantime
so here's our instrumented program and
here might be a program report we have
we see that the branch the bride segment
was observed once it was true ones with
false 20 times and the scalars it was
observed X number of times and number of
times it's true or false we also have
the we also have the success or failure
label of that run so success is is
pretty simple it just succeeded without
any problems a failure could either be a
hard crash or incorrect behavior
anything that the user might label as
incorrect
and we collect a bunch of these program
reports as a success this might be
another success and this might be a
failure so the the thing that we want to
find is we want to zero in on for
instance this predicate because it only
happens during failure and if you look
at remember the virginal snippet of code
you see that what I the loop counter is
in fact never supposed to be greater
than Y so the fact that you observe I
being greater than that that I being
greater than Y it's true in this in this
report is correlated with that failure
okay so that's a quick overview of the
instrumentation and the type of data
that we collect are there any questions
so far okay so now I'm going to
concentrate on the algorithm part what
are the difficult problems for for this
application and before I delve into the
algorithmic challenges I'm going to use
this validation experiment to illustrate
a bunch of our results so Moss is a
software plagiarism detection program it
has about six thousand lines of code and
after instrumentation we ended up with
about 200,000 predicates and the data
set that we collected had roughly
seventeen percent failure rate those
failures came from eight old bugs that
were rien jected into the program these
were either common programming errors or
bugs that had been found during previous
in real bugs that were found in the
program during previous revisions so in
difficulty they range from simple null
pointer dereferences to array overruns
to violations of high-level programming
constructs
I'll taken so we had the source code
rosters make those bears yeah well the
the null pointer some of the simpler
bugs we just are we just injected into
the program they're just calming program
errors okay so they were caught they
were some of them have just understood
that when you say reinjected bulldogs i
bug you meant bullseye Alex made no okay
yeah that was confusing some of them are
bugs that were never in the program
before but they're just common
programming errors that we put into the
program for the sake of experiments yeah
but some of that some of the bugs did it
big did exits the more complicated box
didn't exist in the in the program
before yeah one small question here
injecting the credit gets into the code
is that something that's being that
annually or do you actually have some
automated process automatically yeah so
we check all the branch statements and
we check all the integers scalar
assignments I can we check all the
function return values for instance by
putting in patient errors in what
there's mutation errors um read this way
I'd evils back probably long before
you're born of changing see less than
into a greater than you hate values run
code and see what it has all the
behavior yeah not for this experiment we
haven't I don't think that would be a
challenge that would be different than
then I think that would actually be an
easy error for us to catch but we
haven't experimented with that here well
there was a period of time that if you
made a vacation and it indirectly
behavior the program but my Nicole
probably isn't relevant for the program
I know we haven't experimented with that
not here anyway so the the reason why we
re inject these old bugs is in for the
solid Asian experiments is so that we
know the ground truth and we can verify
the results okay so normally we for
instance we wouldn't know as much about
the bugs as our controlled experiment
here so here's a problem definition
basically the input is a side of program
reports that contains these predicates
truth counts and it contains the outcome
labels and the outcome the desired
outcome is a ranked list of program
predicates hopefully we have one group
one self-contained group of predicates /
bug where the definition of a bug is
something that leads to crashes or
incorrect behavior and that can that's
represented by a single predicate so
we're looking for single predicate
conditions that that tell us what caught
the what's correlated with the failures
okay so so the goal of debunking is
behavior is for this other important
just basically anything that the user
might be note as incorrect it could be
incorrect output it could be something
taking too long I mean is that determine
for each kind of program we want to test
the dessert route College manual effort
is really is required in deciding what
would be incorrect behavior for a given
piece of code um it's all it's purely
manual um the crash is easy which is the
crash is easy all of the most of the
bugs that we have in the validation
experiments is our crashes some of them
are it generates incorrect output but we
have the correct version so we can
compare and automatically determine
whether or not it there was incorrect
output but because because the system is
meant to be used in the field the users
will are the ones in in practice that
sends back these reports so they can
easily enter
take each report as failing or success
or successful it would require it
wouldn't mind just goes yeah unless
you're just trying to catch hard crashes
which which is easy okay so the goal of
debugging even for the one single buck
hayes is to find the single predictor
for each bug where a good predictor is
something that's only true for this bug
now if there's if the if your data set
contains just one bug then it turns out
several solutions work and to illustrate
the these solutions i'm going to use
something called bug histograms so for
each predicate on our list we might have
one of these bug histograms one of these
about histograms where the y-axis are
the number of runs in which this
predicate is true and the x-axis denotes
bug IDs if there's only one bug in the
program then trivially all the bug
histograms look the same they're all
they all concentrate on this one bug and
unfortunately programs contain multiple
bugs in general I know that fact to be
true for mac OS 10 so so the ideal
outcome in that case is we want one
predicate for each bug and the ideal bug
histogram might look something like this
I've ranked the so here's a list of
predicates each one of them has this bug
bug histogram each one of them
concentrates on one and only one bug and
they might be ranked in terms of the
their popularity of how many crashes
they account for so first question that
we want to ask is whether we can treat
this multi bug problem as a single bug
problem to make our life easier so we
tested that assumption on using one of
the single bug algorithm this which is a
to basically two sample t-test where we
test each predicate independently of all
the other predicates and
compare the probability that that
predicate is true in failing runs versus
successful runs yeah pretty much um yeah
and yeah we can think of it as a legal
five problem they I think they do
something they think they're doing
something different but this is
essentially what they're doing and
here's the outcome on Moss so here's a
top ten predicates and what comes out
are you see that we have multiple
predicates all focusing on the same bugs
so the there's there's a bunch of red
there's a bunch of pink and we have
predicates that cover multiple bugs I'm
going to talk more about this kind of
predicates Slater these are what we call
super bugs that cover loosely cover
multiple bugs but are not very useful
for debugging any single one of them so
in short these predators that we get out
from the single bug pretty good single
bug algorithm are redundant and they're
useless for finding out where the bugs
are and they don't cover all of the bugs
so unfortunately we can't reduce the
multi bug problem we can't just treat
the multiple problem as a single bug
problem
yr old predicates bad i think that
multiple Bennigan's might be useful for
somebody going either looking at the
code and saying oh these are two
different conditions no I understand
this one and this is the source of the
bug they are in fact useful but what's
lacking here is a form of organization I
guess because you you don't actually get
to observe the the book histogram and
you don't actually know the book has a
ram in practice so if the programmer has
to go through each predicate on the list
and look at what what look at what it is
and figure out whether it's an
independent bug or something that's the
same as what has come before yeah figure
out how this also relates to modularity
that might be in the in the software so
i might have a multi bug program our
multi boat bug problem where I in fact
had two modules that are in my program
which are failing independently of one
another but it just happens that the
execution traces tends to cause them to
happen in the same runs so is there some
way so you're basically treating a
program is a big omelet and then exit
and an execution as a big model with an
execution of the umpires program I'm
wondering if there's some way to
partition the execution traces and the
programs by modules so that you can
split these these instances where you
have multiple bugs in the same run you
could somehow split them by module so
that they're more like single single bug
problems yeah that is in fact what we
try to do so i'll i'll go through that
next
okay so let's take a look at the multi
bug problem I have a bunch of successful
runs up here I have a bunch of reports
of failing runs down here and how do we
what do we do to solve this problem of
finding out bugs in the multiple
multiple bug case well if in some ideal
world ideal world if the runs were
actually labeled with with the bug label
so suppose we know suppose an Oracle
tells us that runs 1 3 and 5 i'll crash
due to bug number 1 and 2 4 and 6 i'll
crash due to bug number two then you can
analyze each set separately and identify
their set of bug predictors separately
so because we don't have the run labels
the first natural idea is to try to
recover that label and how do we do that
well maybe we can try clustering so
clustering a set of runs as a goal of
reducing the multi bug case multi bug
data set down 2k single bug data sets
where we cluster the runs based on the
program report that contains a predicate
activity patterns so runs that fall into
the same cluster should have the same
set of active predicates here that we
hear the results from applying k-means
to the sets of failing run program
reports it's a lot better than the
results of the simple t-test but we
still have problems with for instance
multiple clusters covering the same bug
and clusters covering multiple bugs so
as it turns out what these run clusters
are zeroing zeroing in on are not
failure modes but usage modes and this
might be clear in hindsight because
the usage modes constitute a much larger
part of the history of a program so the
user spends most of time using the
program than to have it fail yeah I
don't I don't understand why this is the
thing that one would naturally try to
cluster on first it seems like the
natural thing you're on cluster on first
would be something related to know when
I got to a cluster would I be able to
find a good single bug predictor within
it or some notion I but what is that
wrong but we don't have the cluster yet
so first so this is first this is we
first try Custer in the runs and then
for each class or runs we might try to
find a single bug predictor so this is a
first step was thinking that if you had
a if your cost of your clustering was
how good can i be at finding a single
bug within the cluster then that would
feed back into how you modify your
cluster to look for a better clustering
yes yeah I think you're you're jumping
ahead a little bit there's definitely
this this feedback between the quality
of a cluster and the quality of the bug
predictor is that that it comes up when
that's what I'll talk about next okay
yeah
the distance metric of the cluster can
you click any distance okay so predicate
is just zero wanted to or not is that a
predicate is actually we're clustering
on the actual counts so it's the number
of times the predicate is true
okay so another possibility is if say
the bug predictors were known then it we
can use that to separate the clap the
set of failing runs into about in two
different different types of bugs and
then analyze each subset separately to
find out all the other correlative
predicates so the second naive try is to
cluster the predicate and try to recover
the to help through reduce redundancy in
the set of predicates and to recover the
bug IDs here we chose to use spectral
clustering because it respects
transitive relations that might result
from more sampling process so if suppose
a B and C are all equivalent predicates
in our data because we're doing sampling
of the predicates we might only observe
that a and B co-occur and B and C
co-occur but not a and C code and
co-occurring we would still like to put
a a B and C in the same cluster and
spectral clustering tries to accomplish
that the similarity metric that we're
using here is the pairwise correlation
between predicates how often are they
both threw in a set of runs you first
this is this example does k-means
clustering also respect transformations
not as no
oh why not could you explain to me why
not I guess it does so more indirectly I
just you're you're looking at inkay
means you're for each for each predicate
I guess you're looking at how close it
is to the to the center of that how
close it is to the the central predicate
in that cluster right so if two
predicates are both close to the center
then they would fall into the same
cluster but we we are actually looking
for the case where they say a is the
center be as close to it but see may not
be right so so in K means a and B might
be in the same cluster but see would
fall into a different cluster okay in
spectral clustering handles that
difficult what are you take by the
triangle an apology or is there like a
factor of two special clustering has
this graph connotation we're all all the
predicates are related by connected by
certain strength and the clusters are
have to form clusters you basically
you're using you pick up one node and
you see what other nodes follow it and
so so based on the connection strength
so if you pick up a then you would have
you would have be following it and
because b is is following it C would
also follow it so so intuitively close
spectral clustering would get you more
of this transitive relation than camions
does
other question I'm just curious they
tried spectral for clustering runs this
seems like I mean Kimmie's as a number
of problems especially week leading and
product ID based and you have to
Buster's and so it's a traditional
bustering seems like that much better
option on that and the first idea i i i
don't i don't think so i think that you
for for clustering run clustering runs
we really have the problem that the
clusters are not discriminant enough
between different types of clusters
because we we don't want multiple bugs
to end up in the same cluster right
so we can talk about that more later ok
so anyway here the result from spectral
clustering of mass predicates it here in
comparison here is the ideal case that's
what we would like to get and here's a
previous best result from run clustering
and the spectral clustering results are
worse because they have we end up with
predicate clusters that cover a lot of
different bugs and we see over we see a
single bucks being split across multiple
predicate clusters so it turns out that
special clustering doesn't work because
of these super about predictors that
tend to link clusters together these are
these are predators that occur in
multiple different types of bugs and
they tend to alias the bugs together
into a single cluster ok so let's review
some of the problems that we found in
the multi bug case the fundamental
problem is one of missing bug IDs if we
knew which which bug crashed which run
then we can just separate the sets of
different bugs separately and analyze
them separately so the several things
that we tried are trying to recover the
bug IDs through clustering runs but in
that case the problem that we
encountered is that we don't know which
predicates are important to cluster on
and we don't want to cluster on the
entire set of predicates so the next
thing that we try to exploring
predicates and there it turns out we get
the super bug predictors that confound
clusters in a super quick deter is
something like a really trivial one is
something like i entered maine i started
the program that condition is certainly
true for all failures but it's it's not
very so it covers a whole bunch of
failed runs but it's not very useful
because it's also true for successes so
that's a trivial example of a superbug
predictor and
not another one not so trivial one is in
the math experiment we find that a
prominent Super Bowl producer is the
fact that the command line is long so
when the command line is long it might
exercise a whole bunch of options that
are that are rarely used and that might
contain more bugs so the failures are
have have a correlation with a command
line being long but command line being
long is certainly not a bug so that's
the kind of kind of things that we want
to avoid in our in our result some
additional problems include these
redundant predicates so Alyssa predict
is that also be the same thing that
clutter up the ranked list the results
and we haven't talked about how do we
deal with the sparsely sample predicates
okay so but the key insight is that
there is this symmetric relationship
that we should take into account namely
we should be clustering runs by their
buck predictors and clustering and
predicates by the runs that they predict
is that a you have a question and that's
that's similar to this idea of by
clustering that's often used nowadays
for bioinformatics analyzing micro
microarray gene expressions
so to give you a view of the type of
thing that we're trying to accomplish
here here's an ideal set of data where
I've arranged to so now I'm representing
each run as a row vector and I'm
stacking stacking these runs on top of
each other the y axis y axis are the
runs the X axes are the predicate the
the color is red if that predicate is
active in that run and it's white of the
predicate is not active so here we have
the ideal data set where the set of runs
are clearly separated into two two sets
each each set has its distinct bug
predictors and what happens would you
what actually happens is that we have
this much larger chunk of predators that
indicate the usage mode and we might
also have these superbugs superbug
predictors that might be true across all
of the failed runs or at least a large
portion of them and of course in the
real case we also have noisy data so the
predicates don't just behave and they
have more random behavior so they might
be on or off depending on other
conditions and the data is not clearly
organized its shuffled so our problem is
to get from something that looks like
this back to something that looks like
this so the algorithm that I propose to
do that is an iterative voting algorithm
where the predicates compete to account
for failures and the runs cast vote for
for each of the predicate the hope is
that subgroup of runs will reach some
sort of consensus on what's the best
predictor to to represent them and if we
set it up if they if we set up the
system correctly then the strong bug
predictors will win in the
so yeah so sort of an EML gorilla and
what it seems like it's an iterative
algorithm um there's it's it's not IAM
there's no it's not problem it's not a
probabilistic model there's no there's
no hidden there there's no there's no
latent variable that we're trying to
recover but it's it's certainly
iterative okay so is there any other
framework like um that it can be cast as
a as an instance up it's it's it's an
algorithm that tries to find a fixed
point of a set of equations that so it's
so and oftentimes people think of fixed
point equations well one one
interpretation is a fix point equations
try to reach some Maxima of some energy
function of some unknown after my
optimizing objective function okay so
but I just chose this framework because
I find that to be the most natural way
to express what we know about the
problem and the constraints that we
would like it to 20 Bay okay so here's a
representation of the type of objects
that we have in our data set we have a
bunch of right we have a bunch of failed
ones we have a bunch of successful runs
and we get a bunch of predicates so the
first question that we need to answer in
setting up this voting process is how
are the runs link to the predicate
they're linked runs our link two
predicates based on the predicate troof
account but that's that data is sampled
so we want to recover the true
relationship between the runs and the
predicate and we do that by building a
probabilistic model of when a product
when there's a predicate true in a
specific run and we do that in the hope
of reverse reversing the effects of SAR
sampling so you don't actually recover
and Ben's sampling thing it doesn't
really report every single count every
single time no no so I just do it how
does that Marcy visit your favorite
random it's random so essentially for
each each time the program comes across
a predicate and that's inserted it
tosses a coin to determine whether or
not to take that sample that's a more
efficient than just saleable that's not
more efficient than sampling but there's
other tricks that that that they do to
make that faster so so so it actually
doesn't toss one coin at each site and
tosses a geometrically distributed coin
and counts down to the next time when it
takes the next sample and additional
yeah and then there's additional tricks
that they do on top of that to make it
even faster so what this following up on
that is the bias and annoying a function
of where it is in the path in the tree
write a code that uh we actually do do
yeah so it so we could either have it
just the uniform across all predicates
but right now branch then you don't get
any sampling
very little possibility of getting
examples and rear entrances oh yeah yeah
so well it doesn't matter how long the
branches because each each site is
independent independently you
independently decide whether or not to
take a sample for each predicate right
but but with that side we do we do do
this non-uniform sampling where the so
we do some some training runs you know
I'm complete where we just sample
everything and and figure out what's the
general coverage pattern and four for
the predicates that are rarely reached
we would have a higher sampling rate
than the predicates then some new
variable that's executed 10,000 times in
the program then that that has a low
sampling rate ok so the predicate true
probability inference mechanism tries to
infer what was true given what was
observed so the things that we observe
are so this is for a single predicate we
we know how many times it's observed and
true and we also know how many times it
was observed how many times actually
that predicate is actually sampled so
those quantities I'm going to color
green because we observe that in in
practice what we don't know are the
actual number of is the actual number of
times this predicate is true in this run
of the program we also don't know how
many times it's predicate is reached in
this run of the program so here are four
random I'm going to treat them as random
variables and I'm going to endow them
with probability distributions for
instance the number of times that the
predicate is reached is modeled as a
mixture between a Poisson variable and
the spike in zero we made that choice
because i looked at the for complete
data at look at some complete data and
for a large number of predicates the
number of times that this predicate is
reached during a running program if you
look at a histogram it has it looks like
a pass on this
tribution except for cases where that
branch of code is simply not reached
that entire branch is not reaching this
run the program and so it just has the
count is zero so we have this mixture
between a Poisson and spiked at 0 and
similarly we can make modeling choices
about number of times the predicate is
true given that it's reached so these
two variables the probability the
probability distribution for these two
variables are made by modeling
assumptions that come from observations
about real data whereas these two are
exact because they are because they have
to do with a scent with how we do the
sampling and we know exactly how we do
the sampling so this is exactly a
binomial given number of times has
reached was exactly hyper geometric
given them given all the other things in
in our system so given this model we can
place conjugate priors for the
parameters of this model and our job
then is to compute some estimate in this
case I chose the maximum a posteriori
estimate of the model parameters given
data and because we're using conjugate
priors we can write down the posterior
probability that a predicate is true in
some run J in a closed-form formula and
plugging in the S the parameter
estimates we can just come up with a
number so we so the first this first
step gives us a relationship for each
predicate and each run we can write down
the probability that that predicate is
true in that run given the observed
values so so that's the first step this
gives us the adjacency weight matrix
between the runs and the predicate so
the next step is to for each run to
decide how much vote to give to each
predicate
it's going to do that based on some
notion of the quality of a predicate
which I'll talk about later and the
adjacency weight so so given the this
predicate quality which intuitively
should denote how good of a bug
predictor that predicate is given that
quality score and how how each predicate
is related to this run the run might
decide how much about to give to each
predicate and similarly all the other
runs do that decision separately so the
vote from a single run to a single
predicate follows this pattern where the
Q denotes the quality and a ijt knows
the adjacency wait so how do we define
this quality scored well good luck good
luck predictors predictors should have
high quality and for example here's a
really simple bug on null pointer
dereference the fact that pointer is
equal to zero is the smoking gun buck
predictors that we want to one of the
great big bug predictors that we want to
find it's only true in failures and it's
never true in successes on the other
hand its complement pointer not equal
zero is true only in successes not true
in failures and note that it's not the
case that knowing knowing this value
gives you this value because the data
that we have is the count of the number
of times something is true during the
whole run of the program so both if if
this predicate lies on in the path of
some loop then you could have both the
this predicate and this compliment being
true more than more than zero times
during the whole run of the program
right so giving so knowing one is not
equivalent to knowing the other
anyway so based on this intuition it's
harder to we don't have generic metrics
that take into account this relationship
between the predicate and its complement
and and that looks at the successes and
failures so we need to define our own
metric that accounts for these
differences so the quality of a
predicate i define to be this ratio
between how many pounding votes it gets
from the failed runs and the number of
votes are gets from the successful runs
and it depends on the opposite ratio of
the number of votes that its complement
gets from the successful runs and the
failing ones the intuition for this
score is that a predicate I has high
quality if it contributes a lot to the
failed runs the not too successful runs
and and this compliment contributes to
successful runs were not failed ones and
another intuition that you can use is
that the the denominators are
essentially acting as barrier functions
they're acting as as constraints we
really don't want a good predicate to
contribute to successful runs and we
don't want its complement to contribute
to the failed ones okay so how do we
update this this quality score so for
each predicate it looks at the number of
the number of votes it gets from the
failed ones and successful runs and it
looks at number of votes that its
complement gets from the failed ones and
successful runs and it comes up with its
own score and in this case because both
failed runs voted for p1 in both
successful ones voted for P one's
complement aggregating everything it
turns out that p1 is a strong failure p
one looks like a strong failure
predictor whereas for p2p to in this
case got roughly equal amount of votes
from the failed runs and successful runs
and so
they turn out to be mediocre predictors
that are perhaps superbugs because they
got they got votes from failed runs and
a bunch of successful ones okay so
briefly here's the equation whose fixed
point we're trying to find and it's a
nonlinear system and to give you an
overview of the algorithm we we start
with a set of failed ones and the
predicate failed ones and successful
runs in the predicate we initialize the
quality of the predicates to be all want
to be uniform because a priori we do not
have any ideas about what is and what's
not a good buck predictor without
looking at anything else and we also
initialize the adjacency matrix by doing
that probabilistic inference and to
figure out the posterior probability of
the run of the predicate being true in
each run so after that we iterate these
updates for the vote and the the quality
the predicate quality updates until the
process converges at which point each
run casts a final vote for the best
predicate and we rank the predicates by
the number of votes they receive from
failed ones
okay any questions so far yeah have you
looked at whether a program analysis
techniques like static analysis or model
check would help find your quality
measures yeah I haven't looked at it but
that's one of the one of the things that
I think would be really really
interesting and promising to try out
I'll talk more about that later on too
okay so before I before I tell you the
result of applying that algorithm a mas
I'm going to review the previous
attempts so again here's the ideal case
here's what we got from the simple two
sample t-test here's run class here's
what we got from run clustering which is
the best result that we got so far it's
the cleanest and here's what we got from
clustering the predicate so our
algorithm gave us this result on Moss so
it turns out that right away we notice
that bug seven has no independent
predictor we and that's been verified in
our experiment so we're just going to
ignore that bug from from now on the
algorithm successfully picked out five
unique bug predictors for five bucks and
two strong predictors for bug number
eight and two strong predictors for bug
number one so as an example of so this
is this is the bug histogram this is a
book histogram view of the result we
normally don't have this result for a
real program because we don't know which
bug crash which one what we do have are
the actual output so the which
predicates are selected selected to be
important so as an example in this case
for buck number one in moss here's what
the algorithm returned to us and that
leads us to these two lines in the
program where it the program is starting
to look at sea commons and is trying to
match lines on doing doing line counters
and indeed the bug turns out to be one
it's a it has to do with a wrong line
counter in the part of the code that
looks at see comments so that in our in
we count that as a success in our case
so an armed with this knowledge that it
does something useful for the controlled
experiment we went out and got a real
program something that we didn't write
and we had no idea about exif which is
the image processing program it has
about ten thousand lines of code and
after instrumentation we ended up with
156 k predicate so i have to say that we
do we do simple pre-processing to get
rid of a bunch of these predicates but
we still end up with thousands of
predicates that we have to look through
so the on this the Stata said that we
had has a seven percent failure rate
so I also want to mention that the good
thing about our algorithm Annette is
that it's it's linear in the in the
number of predicates times the number of
runs and that's pretty much the best we
can hope for because just to process the
the out that the program reports takes
time linear in the number of runs times
the number of predicates so it's another
reason why we want to set up this
iterative process where each run sorry I
didn't mention this before each run only
looks at its local neighbors the
predicate right and and does it's at
each iteration performance that vote
decision separately from all the other
runs and then each predicate looks at
all the run all the boats that it gets
from from all the runs and also does a
local computation to figure out how what
how to update its quality score yes I
love you take is just uh 20 minutes well
yeah pretty much 20 minutes you ever
find cases where it doesn't converge
know it always converges because the
system is set up the it's we're we're
iterating in a bounded domain at the end
of each iteration we renormalize other
predicate scores so that they sum to
some constant so by brouwer's fixed
point theorem we always converge there
might be multiple fixed points that in
the system but the one that the only one
that that we care about is the one that
we can reach starting from this unit
uniform predicate store because unless
you have some other LS you happen to
have some other information about how
the predicate should be weighted which I
you know the only the only six point
that you care about is the one starting
from the uniform score
as far as 6.05 a brow respects point is
a sorry I didn't see who asked the
question Oh browse fix point is a
general theorem that says if you have if
you have a bound if you're doing a fixed
point iteration in the bounded domain
then you converge then you will find a
fixed point what's that need some
contractility it found the domain you
just go around his abandoned doesn't
mean it converges um I i think the the
condition just says as long as it's
bounded by free little meeting two words
continuous function sorry
that's enough
quality miss the happy ones in some ways
but depending was that the money may not
be able to go back and force it
responded on that you can have a clutch
Adelman where it operates in the you
have some monotonicity
yes as if the I I think I thought the I
I thought that the assumption for four
hours fix point is just that it's
bounded and and it's continuous the
domain the domain is the set of
predicate quality scores so it's always
between 0 and 1 for all the predicate
well you're saying that system
guarantees that there exists a fix point
right you when you're I wouldn't emerge
the fix point but if I start if if the
fixed point exists if the fixed point
exists then I can reach it from any
starting point right department an
objective function could you show that
your algorithm improves the objective
function value at every iteration so I
don't know what's the objective function
that that corresponds to this side of a
big equations
yeah make one way to look at this is
also a question just about step size why
is the particular way in which are
moving at each iteration a good step
size of the racing that's given another
and other optimization problems all
right why do you not to dr. she is it
okay
yeah um
I had I have to think about this more
yeah we can talk about it later okay
anyway applying this applying this
algorithm on this real world example we
found we found three previously unknown
bugs and if we look at one set of these
bugs so for instance once that says that
the program crashed at mem copy that
doesn't give us very much information
but if we look at the algorithm output
we find that if it says that its its
core all does this entire set of crashed
runs is correlated with this condition
where it that where this is true so the
function returns without allocating the
subsequent data blocks so based on the
output you can reconstruct the history
of that program and and say that it must
have entered this function at some
earlier point it returned without
allocating these data blocks and sure
enough subsequently it crashed one is
trying to copy those data blocks off to
another location yeah how another
practice that you find actually wants to
appear in the colitis they all appear in
the code because the predicates are come
from specific lines in in the program
okay no I miss idea that we were you
saying here you said it failed at mem
copy and then how did you get this on
the right uh this is oops
this here on the right the the predicate
highlighted by the algorithm is the
condition that this branch statement is
true men in coffee okay I guess is that
it must have for the set of runs this
must have happened sometime earlier
before it crashed try having it in the
end arrow right they tried to copy this
data off to somewhere else or yeah or
some some other data to to an entry sine
theta so good news if I how to turn up
in every port on there right I thought
what you got was one of em copy what we
got on the left is the stack oh yeah so
if you look at this if you just look at
the stack that's the information that
you get okay I'm retrenchment something
right right yeah okay so construction
does I based on well so this is what the
stack gives you and it's not
mechanically done it's it was just we
just did this here to illustrate how we
found the bug it would be nice to do it
mechanically yeah I don't understand
what what are you saying all
mechanically done so we're not
generating we're not generating a
reconstructed program history for for
the program results we're just
highlighting individual lines in the
code in the original conditions encode
and a person went when you know we went
through and came up with this subsequent
logic
okay so so doing this took less than 20
minutes and this is without prior
knowledge about the code and how how
things work including the mystery yeah
where did you get the test cases to get
here so we actually instrumented exists
and we have a public deployment and
we've been we were collecting data we
noticed that exit has a particularly
high failure rate higher than the other
programs and we looked at so we
generated the this test data in house
given the high failure rate so we just
tested with a whole bunch of images from
all kinds of different sources yeah they
were hard yeah there were there were all
hard crashes yeah the books how the
failure rate change so these three bucks
constituted the entire seven percent of
failure yeah so after we fix these three
bugs there were no more failures in this
in our data set yeah have a mission how
is commending the program terms it's
released its performance so you want to
use the instrumented program in fields
but if departments will be too bad won't
use a little just don't use this
approach sorry can you repeat the
country so how does the instrument in
the program how does it affects it or
for us um it depends on the program
itself we tested the instrument sparse
in the instrumentation with the sparse
sampling rate on a set of computation
heavy programs and the overhead ranged
from one percent to seventy percent but
for interactive programs that overhead
is is less we haven't done user studies
and you know like in real use of
situations how that affects the
the overhead but for programs with tight
loops then the optimization that Ben and
Alex Meyer did it doesn't may not help
so how you first and then have you
looked at kind of ramping up as far as
it is and seeing where where you start
to lose your good at-bats so I'm burying
yours are sampling and see any extent to
which you know how little sampling you
can get away with our house later date
yeah we've done we did we did an
experiment like that I'm moss I don't
know how whether that generator
generalizes to other programs though
yeah one thing about that you know the
one of the problems of a genetic code is
if you're trying to do by race
conditions you changed hi mate so have
you tried running this on any
multi-threaded program and kind of
seeing what happens whether you end up
with more bugs less talk stuff like that
so we did run this on a multi-threaded
program it's an mp3 player called rhythm
box and we found some more calm more
complicated bugs that's that relate
that's timing related but that takes
longer to describe and then this example
yeah so in this example the job on the
screen right now there's this one
predicate that that all is there in all
the pale your cases and it's not there
in all the success cases mm-hmm are
there so so that in the stack trace or
what you use to reconstruct this are
there other products that could aid the
user and try to piece together this
history are there other predicates that
are less of smoking guns but still
yeah certainly in this particular bug
this is the most useful predicate but in
in a lot of the other bugs that we
looked at it definitely helps to get a
to see what are the what's what are the
other predicates in this cluster
predicate to give you a better idea of
what's happening and essentially use
your then arranged list a ranked list
and followed if you click on each
predicate it's always better to look at
the UU you get a cluster of related
predicates and it's all it's often
better to look at the cluster than to
look at individual conditions yeah how
smart are you trying to be and when
you're constructing the credits in the
first place in other words you might
expect the different types of software
would have different types of problems
means yes certainly there are some
commonalities your overruns and so forth
but how are you trying to be at all
clever about thatit is trying to say
we're trying to find a specific class of
bugs and this is what this is useful for
so we're not being very clever about
what to and what not to instrument where
the the predicates are just tossed into
the program automatically and they were
trying to cover as much information as
we can that and we're trying to get
information that we think might be
useful for general types of bugs yeah we
so well there's there's more that we can
do to make that more targeted towards
specific classes of bugs
alright so in summary we have this I
talk to you today about this automatic
debugger for software programs and the
instrumentation and the analysis
framework and showed you that it how it
simultaneously isolates multiple bugs
and the clusters failed runs and
clusters predicates so some of the
interesting problems that came up is
that unlike unlike the usual machine
learning problems we have this problem
has flavors of classification but with
incomplete their failure labels the
flavors of feature selection and it has
feature films flavors of by clustering
but it's different from it has elements
from all three of these problems but are
different from you know the vanilla
version of each one of these so and what
I got out that's project is different
from the I guess the usual machine
learning approach where you might have a
hammer and you're just trying to go
around and look for problems to solve
here we're starting we're taking the
nail oriented approach and starting from
the problem itself and trying to find a
good solution and there are lots of
related work in this area of debugging
and I'm just going to do probably an
unfair survey but you know a sparse
sampling of the current work that's
that's out there there's a suite of work
involving tracking program invariants
and expressions and state changes
there's a lot of work on static
verification and
and one perhaps unorthodox an orthodox
example the static verification is
awesome anglers work on finding bucks in
the old in the old version of the Linux
kernel there's also been some
statistical methods so burn Ellen Erin
coral burn Ellen Horvitz for instance
worked on using this expert crafted
Bayes net Bayesian network to supplement
program analysis to debug a software the
American Airlines flight reservation
system back in the nineteen back in
1990s so a lot of these approaches are
geared towards in-house testing whereas
our approach is unique in that it's
geared towards public equipment so the
premise is that users are already
running these buggy programs so we might
as well make use of those runs and try
to get debugging information for free
and the the approach that is described
today is flexible and and it tries to
handle general types of bugs and
multiple bugs gracefully and it's the
only one that we know of that that tries
to do that so other failure diagnosis
projects that I've worked on our failure
diagnosis for ebay where we had coarse
grain coarse grain instrumentation and
the trade-off there is diagnosis speed
and false positive rates and also a
project at IBM on active diagnosis for
networks so that set up there is we have
some fixed network topology a network of
computers with fixed apology and we have
a fixed set of probes that we can send
into the network to try to diagnose
which node is down for instance and the
algorithm algorithmic problem there the
one that I work on is how to use
probabilistic inference to efficiently
figure out what
next probe to run what's next best probe
to run given the current outputs of
probes that we've already run and
currently I'm working on this problem of
performance diagnosis in a distributed
file system at carnegie mellon so there
the setup is we have some distributed
file system the user comes in on Monday
run some job and the user comes back on
Wednesday runs the same job again but
discovers that this time the system is
much slower so what happened in the
meantime it was there a software upgrade
did so that some of the components go
down so we try to look at snapshots of
containing individual requests traces to
isolate the problem problematic
component so I also worked a little bit
on social network modeling and link
analysis so in general I think networks
and graphs are cool objects to study and
I guess in the long run I want to work
more on this interface between software
and systems and machine learning because
that's an area with a lot of problems in
systems are getting more complex and
everybody needs our help from the
programmers through the administrators
through the users and one of the recent
developments is that instrumented
systems are becoming more available so
we're able to collect more and more data
from these systems but the challenge is
to how do we make use of that data how
do we how do we efficiently deal with
large data sets how we deal with
sampling how do we deal with active
learning problems where for instance in
in the debugging case may be you know if
we take the user into account and if we
take the user into the loop then we can
use it use a user in multiple ways we
can use it to we can use feedback to to
direct instrumentation effort you know
so suppose that we have a certain amount
of overhead that
tolerable we might want we can start
with some general very coarse grains
instrumentation and then successively
focus on the more problematic areas in
the code or we can we might use we're
already using users to sort of label the
runs we can also use the users to
evaluate our results and say you know
these these these predicates are crap
but these other predicates seem like
they're interesting so I want to see
more more information about these two or
the user might tell us or the user or
maybe even some domain knowledge about
the program I tell us these predicates
are actually all the same they're all
related and have some deterministic
relationship so how do we make use of
that information in the learning
algorithm and there's also the problem
of making more extensive use of program
analysis so so far in this approach we
haven't really touched upon we've just
done ly treated each predicate as
independent of all the others there are
a lot more smart things that we can do
using maybe even simple static analysis
to get some limited understanding of the
relationship between predicates and use
that to guide diagnosis efforts or to
clean up the cleanup free process or
post process or just modify the change
in learning algorithm around it there's
a lot of possibilities there so and in
general I think it's really exciting
area so I'd like to work more on that in
the next few years at least
and with that that's the end of the talk
and I want to thank you for coming I'm
asking